Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to control the fate of
liquids in virtual worlds.
This footage is from one of my earlier papers
where I attempted fluid control.
This means that we are not only simulating
the movement of a piece of fluid, but we wish
to coerce it to flow into a prescribed shape.
This was super challenging and I haven’t
really seen a satisfactory solution that I
think, artist could use in the industry yet.
And now that we have these modern, neural-network
based algorithms, we are now able to solve
problems that we never even dreamed of solving
just a few years ago.
For instance, they can already perform this
kind of style transfer for smoke simulations.
Which is, incredible.
So, are you thinking what I am thinking?
Can one of those maybe tackle fluid control
too?
Well, that’s a tough call… just to showcase
how difficult this problem is.
If we wish to have any control over our fluid
simulations, if we are a trained artist, we
can sculpt the fluid directly ourselves.
Of course, this requires a great deal of expertise,
and often, hours of work.
Can we do better?
Well, yes, kind of.
We can use a particle system built into most
modern 3D modeling programs, with which we
can try to guide these particles to a given
direction.
This took about 20 minutes, and it still requires
some artistic expertise.
So, that’s it then?
No, hold on to your papers, and check this
out!
The preparation for this work takes place
in virtual reality, where we can make these
sketches in 3D, and look at that!
The liquid magically takes the shape of our
sketch.
So, how long did this take?
Well, not one hour, and not even 20 minutes.
It took one minute.
One minute.
Now we’re talking!
And even better, we can embed this into a
simulation, and it will behave like a real
piece of fluid should.
So, what is all this good for?
Well, my experience has been in computer graphics
is that if we put a powerful tool like this
into the hands of capable artist, they are
going to create things that we never even
thought of creating.
With this, they can make a heart from wine.
Or create a milky skirt.
Several variants even, if we wish.
Or a liquid butterfly.
I am loving these solutions, and don’t forget,
all of these can be then embedded into a virtual
world and simulated as a real liquid.
Now, we talked about three solutions, and
how much they take, but we didn’t see what
they looked like.
Clearly, it is hard to compare these mathematically,
so this is going to be, of course, subjective.
So, this took an hour.
It looks very smooth, and is perhaps the most
beautiful of the three solutions.
That is great.
However, as a drawback, it does not look like
a real-world water splash.
The particle system took 20 minutes, it creates
a more lifelike version of our letter, but
the physics is still missing.
This still looks like a trail of particles,
not a physics system.
And, let’s see the new method.
Yes, this took only a minute, and it finally
looks like a real splash.
Now, make no mistake, all three of these solutions
can be excellent, depending on our artistic
vision.
So, how does all this magic happen?
What is the architecture of this neural network?
Well, this behavior emerges not from one,
but from the battle of two neural networks.
A generator neural network creates new splashes,
and the discriminator finds out whether these
splashes are real or fake.
Over time, they challenge each other, and
they teach each other to do better.
The technique also goes the extra mile beyond
just sketching.
Look, for instance, your brush strokes can
also describe velocities.
With this, we can not only control the shape,
but even the behavior of the fluid too.
So, there we go.
Finally, a learning-based technique gives
us a proper solution for fluid control.
And here comes the best part - is it not only
quicker than previous solutions, it can also
be used by anyone.
No artistic expertise is required!
What a time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!